[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
pourquoi ray vous new deal deal au
soleil d'île déserte deal mystérieuse
pour répondre à ces questions je reçois
l'historien bruno fuligni qui lance aux
éditions du trésor une nouvelle
collection insulaires et bruno léandri
qui nous rejoindra juste après c'est
l'auteur du premier livre de la
collection sur l'île de marlon brando
alors commençons par vous bruno fuligni
vous êtes historien ce est l'auteur de
plus de 35 livres maintenant pourquoi
cette fascination pour les îles parce
que c'est pas la première fois que vous
publiez des livres qui concerne les îles
on va en voir un certain nombre là mais
au départ pour quoi rêvez-vous deal vous
lui la chance de vivre une partie de ma
vie sur une île de la réunion c'est là
que j'ai appris le français c'est là que
j'ai appris à écrire par exemple mon
père corse même si je n'ai jamais vécu
encore les les ils ont une signification
particulière pour moi y compris dans ma
vie personnelle dans ma construction
et puis je veux qu'il ya un rapport
aussi entre l'île et la lecture
quand on lit un bon livre on a
l'impression d'être sur une terre un
petit peu à l'écart isolé entourée d'eau
et on a d'ailleurs besoin aussi de cette
solitude pour apprécier un bon livre et
du coup lille est un thème littéraire
très important mais donc je me suis
intéressé aux îles à la fois aux îles
dans ce qu'elle pouvait signifier dans
notre imaginaire et puis aux îles vrai
ozil réel qui toutes ont une histoire
est une histoire assez étonnant que le
plus souvent j'ai passé beaucoup de
temps dans ma vie à un scrutin d atlas
vous savez qu'on dit qu'on lit une carte
et dans un atlas n'avait pas du texte
linéaire vous avez au fond des dessins
mais des dessins qui sont parsemés
d'éléments écrit en fait qu'ils sont des
noms territoire des noms d'océan des
noms de courant des villes qui se
promène au milieu de l'océan accroché à
un tout petit bout de terre et j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps à scruter un
petit peu ces atlas ccaf pour essayer de
me repérer
dans la multitude d'îles qui existe à la
surface de notre planète et essayer de
connaître ce qui avait pu se produire
dans saisi les caisses qui avaient pu
conduire des êtres humains à les peuples
et des bouts de roches et parfois très
très inhospitalier perdu au milieu du
pacifique eaux de l'océan indien par
exemple alors justement pendant cette
crise du crâne à virus
j'ai beaucoup scruter les cartes aussi
ai je constatais avec effroi que y avait
la moitié de la planète qu'ils étaient
confinés où pouvait-on fuir et je me
suis mis évidemment rêvé d' île entourée
d'eau isolé en me disant mal à on doit
être tranquille et en même temps pas
tellement j'ai l'impression parce que
quand on regarde tahiti par exemple je
me suis dit naïvement tahiti ils doivent
être tranquille pas du tout haïti
étaient confinés comme la france oui tu
as it is c'est la france
certains points 2 et puis surtout ce qui
est savoureux dans ce que vous nous
raconter c'est que je parlais
d'imaginaire pour tout le monde
tahiti la polynésie c'est vraiment une
île paradisiaque la plus archétypale
quand les premiers européens sont
arrivés
ont découvert cette île ils l'ont appelé
la nouvelle cythère c'était une
référence à l'île d'amour dans
l'antiquité grecque
donc depuis le xviiie siècle nous avons
l'image du nil absolument paradisiaque
or la réalité haïtienne est évidemment
très très différente c'est une île qui a
une histoire violente avec des frictions
politiques régulières et quand même
intense et puis c'est une île qui va
connaître comme les autres territoires
des crises et qui n'a pas été épargné
par le coronavirus d'autres villes
françaises ont été sévèrement touchés
bien sûr dans les antilles et puis si
nous allons dans l'océan indien il y à
mayotte qui risque de rester la dernière
tâche rouge dans les prochaines cartes
mayotte effectivement c'est sévère on
voir je vous parlais de la réunion vous
avez parlé passé une partie de votre
enfance
la réunion était assez épargné les seuls
cas de cauna à la réunion ce sont
justement des malades de mayotte qu'on a
importé dont un qui malheureusement est
décédé à la réunion enfin c'était un
portait de mayotte
voilà une île qui a été me semble-t-il
relativement épargné par par cette
pandémie mondiale
maintenant mieux c'est un petit paradis
de la réunion on y mange bien il y fait
un temps agréable et on y trouve une
population assez unique au monde puisque
contrairement à d'autres cibles île de
la réunion n'était pas peuplé quand les
européens l'ont découvert et donc tous
les gens qui habitent l'île de la
réunion viennent d'ailleurs alors lier
l'asie l'afrique l'europe l'amérique
vraiment de partout et il ya eu un
mélange assez étonnant assez unique au
monde
sur cette île c'est une île
tout à fait singulière et puis c'est
aussi un volcan est ce que j'ai retenu
dieu sait si j'étais jeune quand j'ai
vécu à l'île de la réunion c'est qu'une
île c'était à la fois un paradis un
enfer est le cadet de la réunion est
vraiment exemplaire de ce point de vue
là puisqu'en fait c'est un énorme volcan
est donc vous vivez très agréablement
sur une île très belle mais
régulièrement et bien vous vous savez
qu'il va y avoir une éruption et vous
jusqu'à maintenant la lave coule du bon
côté c'est à dire du côté de l'océan et
donc chaque année l'île s'agrandit 1 la
france donc ça grandit un petit peu
chaque année avec ses coulées de lave
qui vont vers l'océan est qui et qui
durcissent mais vous êtes quand même au
milieu de l'océan
les pieds sur quelque chose qui pourrait
éventuellement un jour exploser ou
oussou devenir un feu un brasier
gigantesque et à hauteur d'enfant sait
c'est très singulier c'est inoubliable
d'être sur cette île qui a toutes les
apparences d'un petit paradis et qui est
peut-être une bombe
il ya une autre île qui étape comme ça
que je connais bien ce sont les açores
des açores vous êtes soit vous êtes
devant le volcan soit vous êtes au pied
du volcan soit vous êtes dans le volcan
puisque le cratère peut faire jusqu'à 15
km de diamètre
revenons à votre premier livre au
premier livre que vous avez consacré à
une île c'était en 2003 ça s'intitule l
île à éclipses alors lille à éclipse
qu'est ce qu'elle est particulier c'est
une histoire fascinante une histoire
extraordinaire alors nous restons dans
le monde du volcanisme finalement et en
on annonce qu'une île nouvelle vient
d'apparaître au coeur de la méditerranée
donc la mer la plus anciennement connu
la plus anciennement cartographier dont
on croit connaître le moindre recoin et
bien vient de s'enrichir d'une ligne
nouvelle et où ça entre la sicile et
malte c'est à dire à un point tout à
fait stratégique celui qui tiendrait
cette île nouvelles et bien contrôlerez
tout le trafic maritime entre la
méditerranée orientale la méditerranée
occidentale entre l'europe et l'afrique
aussi donc ça devient
immédiatement cette idée nouvelle un
enjeu est donc les napolitains d'abord
essaye de s'en emparer mais lille est
encore brûlante donc il ne débarque pas
ils font le tour en bateau il jette une
rame en considérant qu'ils en ont pris
possession pour le roi de naples et des
deux siciles ferdinand donc lille le
eelv on l'a baptisé ferdinand des as les
anglais arrivent parce qu'ils sont à
malte à l'époque il veut ne surtout pas
qu'ils aient une deuxième malte qui
viennent faire pièce à leurs places
fortes
mais là encore ils ne peuvent pas
débarquer où ils n'y arrivent pas donc
ils tirent 21 coups de canon ils
prennent possession des personnes ne
débarquent ils vont l'appeler ni le
drame du nom du premier lord de
l'amirauté à l'époque
et alors les français cette
extraordinaire arrivent bons derniers
dans cette course mais par contre font
les choses dans les règles et par
ailleurs les français débarque mais
débarque sous couvert d'une expédition
scientifique
alors bien sûr il déploie le drapeau
français prennent possession mais c'est
pas du tout les deux listes c'est pour
faire avancer les sciences c'est pour le
bien de l'humanité
et là il ya quelque chose d'extrêmement
français dans la façon dont on s'empare
de cette île est par ailleurs c'est pas
purement à camouflage il y a vraiment un
géologue un jeune géologue constant
prévost qui a été embarquée elle et
c'est un texte remarquable
description cette île mais aussi un
risque vécu de ce qu'est au fond la
journée d'un homme qui débarque sur une
terre que personne n'a jamais foulée
avant lui est une terre qui vient
d'émerger qui est encore chaude on lui
peut il marcher mais le sol est encore
chaud il ya encore des vapeurs qui sort
donc il nous décrit on est dans les
années 1830
évidemment en plein tourbillon
romantique donc très très vite la
sciences géologiques cède le pas à
toutes sortes de références littéraires
religieuses et les athées à tout un une
oeuvre finalement qui est rédigé la à
chaud sans jeu de mots par ce jeune
géologue fasciné par son objet et donc
la france est très fier d'avoir augmenté
son territoire de cette île stratégique
et d'avoir fait pièce aux britanniques
et quelques mois après donc on envoie
une force militaire un peu plus
conséquente pour vraiment occupé lead on
a pris possession
de la science c'était bien mais on va
passer aux choses sérieuses et là on a
un rapport beaucoup moins littéraire un
peu pathétique d'un amiral vraiment
blanchi sous le harnais qui ne comprend
pas qui fait refaire refait ses calculs
il ne trouve pas cette satanée une
nouvelle qui a émergé en méditerranée
tout simplement parce qu'elle a disparu
c'est à dire que cette île ferdinand des
à julia pour les français g pour les
anglais bien c'était un tas de cendres
volcaniques sortie d'un volcan sous
marin
et puis avec l'action des vagues avec
l'action du vent et bien ce tas petit à
petit s'est dispersé et bien il ya
toujours une sorte de montagnes sous
marines mais elle ne dépasse pas le
niveau de la mer et aujourd'hui encore à
l'emplacement de cet exil là si j'ose
dire et bien se trouve une montagne
sous-marine un volcan sous marin dont la
pointe extrême est à 8 mètres de la
surface de la mer
la question se pose évidemment c'est
imaginons qui est demain une petite
secousse tellurique que de nouveaux sets
ils apparaissent
est ce que les français la réclameront
voilà la question est posée
elle n'est jamais réapparue depuis sa
première
hé hé
a paris sur l a fait des petits coucous
b très bref
en 1831 ça a été une éruption importante
et donc lille est restée visible pendant
plusieurs mois et on pouvait marcher
dessus à plusieurs reprises en 1893 en
1930 des marins des pêcheurs ont dit
avoir vu une petite émergence donc il ya
eu peut-être quelques mètres carrés de
terres nouvelles
qui ont comme ça et donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai appelé salida éclipse parce
qu'effectivement elle apparaît elle
disparaît les très capricieuse
finalement 7
julia on a beaucoup de mal à s'en
emparer nous échappe en permanence
pourtant on sait très précisément où
elle est on a ses coordonnées
géographiques absolue mais voilà qu est
ce qu une île quand elle est sous la mer
ça n'est plus une île mais à quand elle
a le pouvoir de remonter de temps en
temps et de disparaître
là ça devient tout à fait fascinant
d'ailleurs le cas n'est pas complètement
unique un ya d'autres îles dans d'autres
zones volcaniques qui comme ceux là
apparaissent disparaissent omneari
falcon dans le dans le pacifique pour et
qui ont des histoires un peu similaire
mais c'est vrai que dans le cas de dean
julia au coeur du vieux monde au milieu
de la méditerranée avec cette rivalité
c'était très intéressant et puis
évidemment cette affaire en 1831 et
ensuite a fait tellement de bruit que
c'est il a inspiré aussi de très grand
écrivain et c'est cela qui m'intéressait
aussi puisque on va trouver une julia
aussi bien dans l'oeuvre de jules verne
que dans celle de walter scott et de et
de différents écrivains qui vont broder
sur cette histoire incroyable parce qu
imaginer qu'on est caché un trésor sur
cette île au moment où elle émergeait et
que
eh bien il faille attendre maintenant
qu'elle remonte pour récupérer le trésor
évidemment ça fait un scénario tout à
fait intéressant alors vous avez de
publier un autre livre très intéressant
attitudes et les terres du monde
elles attendent et je ne vois plus rien
tour du monde des terres françaises
oubliées excusez moi un livre que
j'avais dévoré l'époque en plus et dans
lequel vous fait évidemment un tour du
monde de toutes les possessions
françaises que nous les français ne
connaissons pas où nous avons oublié
il y avait notamment les îles
chesterfield
alors pourquoi est ce que c'était les
l'histoire des îles celle serre-file
pourquoi est-elle passionnante
bon on dirait un gag déjà vous voyez
c'est un drôle de nom pour un archipel
français les îles chesterfield c'est
étonnant et puis si on regarde sur un
atlas des îles chesterfield elles sont
au large de l'australie
et je ne vous parle pas d'un souvenir
historique
aujourd'hui encore la france possède un
archipel au large de l'australie mais
n'y a pas un français qu'ils le sachent
c'est totalement oublié négligé et c'est
bien dommage
alors bien sûr ce sont de toutes petites
îles il ya une soixantaine d'îlots de
recife et tous ensemble ne représente
que 1 kilomètre carré un carré d'un km
de côtes et de terre ou de sable ou plus
on puisse marcher
sauf que cette poussière deal elle
s'étend sur vingt mille kilomètres
carrés détendu océanique donc c'est une
zone assez large en fait alors très peu
fréquenté pendant très longtemps c'est
il n'appartenait à personne
c'était un peu un repaire de baleiniers
à l'époque on faisait la chasse à la
baleine avec les harpons etc
les baleiniers de toutes les nations il
relâche et là il chassait marché un
petit peu c'était un peu un endroit de
pause il n'y avait pas vraiment de deux
revendications sur sur saisine elle
s'appelle chesterfield parce que c'est
un navire anglais qui avait failli
couler et qu'il s'appelait le secteur
fils d'un tout simplement et donc le
capitaine avait signalé ces îlots comme
on en fait des parages dangereux mais
sans penser une seconde a débarqué à
prendre possession
et donc c'est ils sont restés très très
très très longtemps
dans l'ain détermination et simplement
ce qui s'est produit à la fin du 19e
siècle
c'est que un anglais s'est présenté en
nouvelle calédonie donc pas très loin et
il voulait qu'on lui fasse crédit parce
qu'il a il devait aller un petit peu
plus loin dit chesterfield alors il y
avait un français qui voulaient bien dû
prêter de l'argent qu'ils voulaient bien
ddb qui ai voulu en savoir un petit peu
plus et qui pour cela a eu la bonne idée
de le faire boire l'anglais lui offrir
une série de tournées et l'anglais a
fini par parler expliqué qu'il allait
prendre possession des îles chesterfield
pour son gouvernement de façon à
exploiter le guano parce qu'à la fin du
19e siècle on s'était rendu compte que
lugano donc qui sont des cousins de
déjections d'oiseaux de mer desséché
c'est du phosphate purée c'est très
utile comme fertilisants dans
l'agriculture et donc il ya eu une
véritable ruée sur le guano un petit peu
comme il ya eu des rebelles vers l'or
c'est moins nobles mais ça a rapporté
beaucoup d'argent et les secteurs field
évidemment qui sont recouvertes en
permanence d'une nuée d'oiseaux de mer
qui ne pas se perd pas en manger du
poisson et et à rejeter ce que vous
aimez gilles éthier et bien décelé une
véritable mine à ciel ouvert quoi et
donc on fait boire cet anglais et quand
il est ivre mort et bien elle cite jean
des mazures ce français de
nouvelle-calédonie court prévenir le
gouverneur en disant attention les
anglais vont s'emparer des chesterfield
et ses îles qu'on avait regardé comme
rien comme totalement négligeable
pendant des décennies
tout à coup deviennent un enjeu est donc
on envoie un navire de guerre et on a
réussi de la prise de possession
officiel on tire 21 coups de canon
présente les couleurs on débat et on y
exploite le guano et là où la france est
une nation extraordinaire c'est qu'à
partir du moment où le guano et
exploités sous le pavillon tricolore
évidemment c'est à elle cite jean des
mesures en récompense qu'on a concédé le
droit d'exploiter le guano à ce moment
là on débarque un inspecteur du fisc et
il va y avoir pendant plusieurs mois un
fonctionnaire des contributions qui va
être là pour constater les tonnes de
bois no extraites et pour prélever 1
francs par tonne de guano il va tenir
quelques mois sur une île où y arrive
un gaz du caca d'oiseaux de mer concassé
des ouvriers et puis sa petite cabane
visiblement d'après les rares traces
écrites qu'on est allé là bas avec sa
femme donc on a un couple un
fonctionnaire et sa femme qui sont là
pour constater pour prélever et puis au
bout d'un moment ils s'en vont donc on
ne sait pas qui a craqué en premier
et finalement le guano sera exploité
sous le régime d'une simple déclaration
il y aura plus de contrôle sur place de
centres adverses il nous reste un
archipel
aujourd'hui encore le les chaises de
frites sont françaises et autre destin
original c'est l'île de clipperton qui
était et qui figure également dans ce
livre il le gripen fait beaucoup rêver
elle est donc dans le pacifique mais
assez loin des chesterfield puisque là
on est dans le pacifique nord à la
hauteur du mexique est d'ailleurs le
mexique pendant très longtemps à
revendiquer un l'île de clipperton
considérant qu'elle lui appartenait et
qu'elle appartenait avant aux espagnols
sauf que les français ont en ont pris
possession ou xviiie siècle possession
confirmé sous le second empire au 19e
siècle et à un moment donc français et
mexicains quand même pas se battre pour
un atoll désertique de sept kilomètres
carrés ont confié à l'arbitrage au roi
d'italie est non tant longtemps
longtemps plus tard ou sous mussolini
est bien le roi d'italie pour des
raisons diplomatiques voulait faire
plaisir à la france avant une importante
conférence sur les armements navals a
déclaré à la surprise générale et alors
que tout le monde avait oublié ce
contentieux que clipperton était une île
française
même l'ambassadeur de france à rome est
très embêté heures dix ans de l'équipe
burton qu'est ce que c'est que ça qu'est
ce qu'on va en faire bertone plus tard
va être occupé par les américains
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale et de
gaulle va piquer une vraie colère pour
dire mais non c'est un territoire
français vous n'avez rien à faire là et
lorsque de gaulle deviendra président de
la république lui va vraiment faire en
sorte de rendre visible la souveraineté
française à clipperton en organisant
régulièrement des expéditions
scientifiques lient les n'a aucun
habitant
mais elle possède un code postal ce qui
est quand même extraordinaire et il ya
un véritable intérêt
à détenir cette ive c'est une île je
voulais dit de sept kilomètres carrés
plutôt anatole une sorte d'anneau comme
cela très inhospitalière j'ai pas le
temps de raconter son histoire dans le
détail mais ceux qui ont tenté d'y vivre
s'en sont mordu les doigts sauf que ces
sept kilomètres carrés en plein océan
pacifique d'abord donne à la france une
zone économique exclusive de plus de 400
mille kilomètres carrés
sept kilomètres carrés de terres sont
entourés de quatre cent mille kilomètres
carrés d'eau et ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que cette zone est plus grande
que l'allemagne et puis du coup c'est
l'unique territoire français du
pacifique nord bien sûr il ya la
polynésie où alice et futuna nouvelle
calédonie mais ça c'est dans le
pacifique sud
clipperton dans le pacifique nord ça
permet à la france de siéger cénacle
diplomatique qui est responsable des
questions sur le pacifique nord et donc
la france
je dirais à égalité avec les états unis
la chine le japon siège cette
organisation parce qu'elle possède les
sept kilomètres carrés des articles de
clipperton donc il y avait aussi un
intérêt stratégique et diplomatique à
détenir cette île foot français savent
que clipperton ça fait six anglais ça
explique aussi pourquoi nous avons le 2e
plus grand domaine maritime du monde
presque à égalité avec les états unis
c'est justement grâce à des îles
totalement isolé comme clip horton qui
avec leurs quelques kilomètres car elle
nous donne des centaines de miles de 2,2
de domaine maritime c'est ça parce qu'il
ya non seulement les eaux territoriales
mais bien plus largement les zones
économiques exclusives donc quand vous
avez une île qui est perdue au milieu de
l'océan on trace un grand cercle autour
et ça peut représenter 400 500 mille
kilomètres carrés si lille est très
isolé alors il ya bien sûr le cas des
îles du pacifique comme clipperton où
les différents archipels de la polynésie
française et des n'oublions pas que la
france est très présente aussi dans le
sud de l'océan indien avec les terres
australes et antarctiques françaises
les fameuses îles kerguelen par exemple
amsterdam saint paul est bien là aussi
ce sont des domaines colossaux pour des
îles tout petit et qui n'ont pas de
population permanente
il ya des bases avec des scientifiques
quelques techniciens de temps en temps
quelques militaires mais sur le fond il
n'y a pas de population permanente sont
des terres très inhospitalière en
revanche
eh bien ce sont des zones très
intéressante à tous points de vue au
plan historique au plan scientifique au
plan de la climatologie
de toutes les manières et le patrimoine
français et est pour ainsi dire
inépuisable avec ses sept présences tout
autour du monde et le grand paradoxe
c'est que la plus petite commune de
métropole à un maire des parlementaires
pour la défendre pour la faire connaître
alors que ces territoires qui sont
peut-être fondamentaux pour notre avenir
au fond sont peu connues peu défendu et
donc j'ai essayé avec ce livre de faire
prendre conscience à nos compatriotes
que au fond aujourd'hui je ne parle pas
de l'époque coloniale je dis aujourd'hui
on peut faire le tour de la planète sans
quitter la france d'îles en îles tout
autour du monde
eh bien il ya toujours une petite terre
un rocher un îlot un archipel une
enclave
français alors dans ce même livre je me
souviens qu'il y avait également
l'histoire du récif ernest legouvé dit
nous racontez nous rapidement il nous
reste quelques minutes le récif ernest
legouvé et on le trouve sur les atlas
c'est vraiment un tout petit point de
rien du tout bon et dans une zone assez
inhospitalière puisque c'est certes dans
l'océan pacifique mais l'extrême sud de
l'océan pacifique en allant vers
l'antarctique une zone où on navigue
assez peu en 1903 ce récit fait signalé
par le capitaine d'un navire qui
s'appelle ernest legouvé le navire 1
s'appelle comme ça par le capitaine
s'éteindre nature ce qui est à la mode à
l'époque un peu oublié aujourd'hui et
l'armateur admirait cet écrivain était
proche de lui et donc lavées donné son
nom à un navire le navire signalant à
recife
le récit prend le nom de l'écrivain
c'est à dire ernest legouvé est donc la
nouvelle fait un petit peu le tour du
monde on a découvert un récif très
isolée dans le pacifique sud et donc il
va être portée sur les quarts les atlas
qui est tout à fait normal et
aujourd'hui encore on le trouve dans bon
nombre de places sauf qu'aujourd'hui on
s'est rendu compte qu'il n'y avait pas
de recife ernest legouvé et peut-être
bien qu'il n'ya jamais eu de recife
ernest coovi c'est pas forcément détruit
ou enfoncé sous la mer en fait si on
regarde de près ernest legouvé était un
ami de jules verne
c'est lui qui a soutenu jules verne
quand jules verne a tenté sans succès
d'entrer à l'académie française et les
coordonnées géographiques des renaître
gouver à un chouia prêts sont celles de
tabor c'est-à-dire l'île mystérieuse la
fameuse île mystérieuse où se réfugient
le capitaine nemo est donc forte fortes
présomptions pour qu'ils aient eu en
fait un canular génial avec un armateur
un écrivain autres écrivains qui ont
réussi à hofu faire inscrire sur les
cartes les plus sérieuses et bien une
île totalement imaginaire et voyez c'est
typiquement le genre d'histoire moi qui
me met en joie parce que
au fond l'existence d'un bout de rocher
au fin fond du pacifique sud dans une
zone totalement inhabitable n'a guère
d'intérêt
mais si ce rocher où cette illusion de
rochers finalement pour provient d'une
oeuvre de l'esprit provient d'une oeuvre
d'un écrivain comme jules verne et finit
par prendre la forme d'une hydre est
elle là ça devient très intéressant
parce que ça brouille complètement la
distinction qu'on fait souvent entre
fiction et réalité avec les îles on est
toujours dans un entre deux entre le
fantasme l'imaginaire le
le mirage et puis la géographie
l'histoire le savoir qu'on considère
comme objectif même s'il ne l'est pas en
fait
alors parmi les fantasy à celui de l'île
déserte je peux pas résister au plaisir
de vous montrer la dernière que j'ai
approché c'est d'ailleurs dans le
pacifique sud c'est à ces sept en
nouvelle-calédonie une île déserte très
célèbre elle fait la couverture de géo
je crois le magazine
il déserte en fait on le voit bien au
cinéma dans les romans dieu c'est sûr de
parler d' île déserte
elles ne sont jamais tout à fait des
herbes d'ailleurs on y rencontre
toujours robinson crusoé rencontre vite
vendredi je crois qu'il ya que le film
avec tom hanks seul au monde où il garde
les une tombe sur une île déserte qui
restent désertes jusqu'à la fin en dépit
de sa présence à lui mais sinon les îles
désertes ne le reste jamais très
longtemps est ce qu'il y a encore des
îles désertes
répondez-moi très vite parce que bruno
fuligni parce qu'on va rejoindre bruno
landry bardon un bruno landry pourra
compléter ma réponse mais il y a des
îles qui sont passagèrement déserte
l'unil s'est ouvert s'est offert si vous
avez un bateau et que vous êtes
suffisamment habile vous pouvez aborder
et donc il ya aujourd'hui dans les
initiateurs field il ya 60 kg sans aucun
habitant
et il ya des îles aussi peu fréquentée
qu'ils n'ont même pas encore de nom vous
pouvez donner votre nom ou le nom d'une
personne chère à un îlot aujourd'hui
comme au temps de la marine à voile
encore faut-il y aller et puis si jamais
vous mettez le pied sur un de ces lots
eh bien je pense que tout comme le
contrôleur du fisc chargés du guano au
19e siècle vous n'y resterais peut-être
pas toute votre vie
donc je pense pas qu'il y ait des îles
totalement déserte
aujourd'hui mais il y a des îles
inhabitées sur lesquels on peut passer
et puis surtout sur lequel on peut
fantasmer on va faire une pause on se
retrouve ensuite avec bruno les
rodrigues qui publie le premier livre de
votre collection insulaire consacré à
une île qui avait fait fantasmer marlon
brando c'est l île déserte dans toute sa
splendeur
elle est devenue l'île de marlon brando
on en parle juste après
[Musique]
nous voilà de retour avec toujours bruno
fuligni qui lance cette nouvelle
collection aux éditions du trésor
intitulé insulaires et bruno léandri
l'auteur de la grande encyclopédie du
dérisoire qui vient donc de publier
l'île de marlon brando dans la
collection insulaire l'île de marlon
brando
elle s'appelle détia torah en voici la
carte telle qu'elle figure d' je
l'aimais le prénom ce verdict me bruno
landry
c'est à tetiaroa tetiaroa j'ai rajouté
un thé pardonnez moi et voici la carte
telle qu'elle figure dans le dans le
livre c'est donc elle fait à peu près 6
km² 1 c'est ça est ce que vous y est
allé d'ailleurs bono non non jamais
j'aimerais que j'aimerais bien mais je
suis paré et 7 km de diamètre l'ado
diamètre et 7 km de diamètre et la tôle
comprend stress petits îlots ils sont
vraiment petits groupes
c'est sur le tournage de des révoltés du
bounty en 1960 que marlon brando a
découvert sept îles
il est tombé tout de suite amoureux
c'est le fantasme de l'île déserte pour
une star aussi énorme qu'il était à
l'époque
évidemment ça doit être tentant de fuir
la foule et de se retrouver dans un
endroit où personne d'autre ne peut ne
peut accoster
comme tout le monde le sait pas quand
même un acteur un comédien pas comme les
autres et c'était un homme à lui bien
qu'il passe est venu bien d'autres et
puis en pendant le tournage des révoltés
du bounty et à cette lubie qui lui est
tombée dessus de l'île déserte
il connaissait pas la polynésie en
général et au mode de vie le climat et
d'un seul coup il découvre des millions
de choses qui me parle énormément les
les jeunes filles dénudées et les
cocotiers la chaleur les fleurs il
trouve ça merveilleux et puis a sauté il
est investi ce fantasme de l'île déserte
parce que si un homme au monde qui ait
les moyens ce pays à l'époque j'en ai
alors on va voir que c'est ce fantasme
de l'île déserte il a quoi il est
accompagné d'un autre fantasme pour une
jeune femme prénommée taristas qui avait
19 ans à l'époque et qui joue sa sa
fiancée dans ce très très très mauvais
film il faut bien reconnaître qu'ils
étaient les les révoltés du bounty
réalisé par lewis milestone
mais revenons justement sur l'histoire
des mutinés du bounty on la connaît tous
cette histoire il ya eu trois
adaptations cinématographiques ce qu'on
sait moins c'est ce que venait faire le
bounty
ap à tahiti à l'époque pourquoi ce
navire de l' anglais arrive-t-il à
tahiti vous le racontez dans votre livre
il vit à chercher un arbre un arbre
particulier qu'on va voir en photo
l'arbre à pain c'est ça la part rapport
donnant un fruit à ces gros comme ça qui
est un traitement et twitteront quand il
est loin et les thèmes et styles
il est c'est pas terrible mais ça ça se
mange tellement jav simple accompagner
plein de plats avec avec des épices avec
de la viande sais pas mais c'est surtout
très nourrissants et et sa touche
facilement donc quand on quand on crève
de faim quand il ya des pénuries aussi
où cela il ya toujours le pain qui tombe
de l'arbre à pain c'est quand même un
l'art du seigneur donc les les anglais
avaient été enlevées envoyé un bateau
pour prendre cet arbre rapport et l'a
planté dans des îles vous avez des
problèmes avec leurs colonies des
problèmes avec leurs esclaves problèmes
avec leur personnel c'était plus facile
pour les nourrir
ça coûtait moins cher si on avait pu
faire pousser l'arbre à pain dans ces
îles a donc il a envoyé le bounty
chercher et plants d'arbres à pain pour
les planter dans d'autres ils étaient en
possession
alors pourquoi les marins du bounty ce
sont-ils mutinés il faut savoir qu'à
l'époque la royal navy c'est la marine
la plus puissante du monde
mais c'est aussi l'une des plus cruelles
les le traitement des traitements dont
sont victimes les équipages sont
absolument inhumain sachant en plus
qu'une partie de ses équipages ont été
recrutés de force et donc il y aura
plusieurs mutineries à la fin du xviiie
siècle il y en a des célèbres comme
celle de spie trade est celle de la
naure s'étendit 797 en 1789 la première
célèbre c'est la révolte des mutinés du
bounty et elle éclate trois semaines
après avoir quitté tahiti on peut
imaginer qu'il ya eu un rapport ils sont
très très maltraité ses marins y compris
le second du fameux capitaine bligh
fletcher christian incarné par marlon
brando dans le film se fait chair
christian lui même subi un traitement
inhumain et ça explose trois semaines
après avoir accosté à tahiti donc le le
contraste a dû jouer entre ce paradis
qui est éthique on imagine et et le
retour à bord d'un bateau
ou on est battu ou on est puni
systématiquement
oui bien sûr c'est exactement ça aucune
marine il n'y avait pas que l'appareil
anglaise aucune marine l'été temps avec
ses équipages à l'époque c'était et
marins s'étaient pas ému les profs qu'il
fallait revenir et c'était extrêmement
difficile et il a eu les brimades que le
capitaine bligh imposait à ses hommes
qui sont avérées connectés il ya eu des
témoignages etc et j'étais pas pire que
faisaient les choses n importe quel
capitaine sur quels autres bateaux
simplement là les circonstances ce
voyage a été plus long que prévu et les
hommes on avait simplement un petit peu
plus marquée que prévu par rapport à
d'autres voyages
s'y ajoute en plus un antagonisme entre
leur le capitaine et son second qu'il
faut pas l'oublier
avant le avant le voyage étaient des
grands copains donc on seront ni magie
de leur relation du s'envenimer de
manière un peu plus violente que ceux
qui seraient passés dans une des rares
filles normales
enfin quand il arrive à tahiti 1 les
hommes en ont marre blige et fletcher ne
doit se sentir et il découvre un paradis
il est pour la liberté en plus le bateau
doit attendre parce qu'il s'est dit il
c'est pas la bonne saison pour les plans
et donc voilà on laisse ces hommes qui
sont ils sont malheureux ce second qui
est frustrés et en colère on les laisse
en liberté tranquille ils connaissent le
paradis et voilà qu'au moment de
repartir
il ya un malaise c'est très visible
pour moi ça a été la même chose et là je
me tourne vers bruno fuligni parce que
vous nous disiez tout à l'heure au début
de cette émission tahiti on le voit
comme un paradis mais c'est pas
seulement un paradis c'est vrai mais
reconnaissez quand on voit tel type la
première fois surtout quand on arrive de
grande bretagne
ça ressemble quand même terriblement
paradis oui surtout après la dureté de
la traversée au xviiie siècle qu'on a
vraiment l'impression d'avoir découvert
le paradis terrestre
bien sûr que soit les français les
anglais là dessus tout le monde et tout
le monde est d'accord
après les choses vont se gâter parce que
les européens à ramener les maladies
vénériennes parce que lille va devenir
un enjeu politique enfin pour toutes
sortes de raisons mais sur le moment
pour le marin de base c'est inespéré
non seulement lille est magnifique on y
trouve des fruits à profusion on y mange
bien et sait mais il ya ces femmes
magnifiques et avec des moeurs dont en
europe on n'avait pas idée est au fond
le mythe du bon sauvage qui va exister à
partir de ce moment là il vient en
partie des récits de navigateurs qui ont
abordé à tahiti donc retourné sur un
navire retrouvé la discipline militaire
navale très très dur après plusieurs
mois passés à tahiti non c'était
évidemment pas possible ils sont très
sympas les mutilés du bounty on use
aurait pu y goûter leur capitaine
mais non il le met sur une chaloupe avec
les marins qui lui sont restés fidèles
et c'est un sacré marin quand même le
capitaine bligh il va faire 6500 km il
va arriver aux nouvelles 1-2 occidentale
néerlandaise pardon la nouvelle guinée
je crois à peu près et de là il va
revenir en angleterre et puis il va
envoyer on va renvoyer un bateau pour
pour choper les métiers du bounty ceux
qui sont est resté à tahiti vont être
emmené en angleterre certains seront
pendus d'autres amnistiés ou ou
innocente et d'ailleurs et puis les
derniers avec fletcher christian ils
vont trouver une île encore plus isolé
c'est pitcairn je crois que c'est l'île
la plus isolée du monde celle qui
aimerait plus loin au centre du
pacifique et ils vont finir tous par
s'entretuer je crois c'est le non
seulement qu'il crée
tu veux ni vraiment totalement isolé par
rapport à tous les archipels du secteur
mais en plus à l'époque ses coordonnées
n'étaient pas les bonnes
donc même touria laisse on voulait on
n'y arrivait pas c'était par erreur
quand tombé dessus et c'est par erreur
en secte par hasard fletcher et ses
compagnons tombe sur cette île là et il
a elle pouvait pas trouver meilleur
planque parce que même la royal navy
savait aller poursuivre pendant des
années des années jusqu'à la trappe et
il la voyait la royal navy avait les
moyens
mais dans cette île il savait que là il
serait bien planqué est peinard et donc
la première chose qui fait quand il a
fait brûler son bateau pour que personne
ne le retrouve et cette petite
communauté de ses marins endurci quand
même et qui étaient pas des humains
assez fort et de la connaissance et la
nature de la nature sauvage des
indigènes des polynésiens qui avait
emmené avec eux eh ben ça va permettre à
cette communauté de s'implanter dans
l'huile et prodige rare de survivre et
de 2,6 pérenniser le stuff s'il est
celui de ce qui arrive évidemment
finissent par à se taper dessus et santé
s'entretuent
quand même l'iso fait les enfants et les
enfants vont faire des enfants et ça va
donner lieu à une population qu'il a
perduré
juste à nos jours et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je crois qu'une
cinquantaine d'habitants et petit cam
qui descendent pas à peu près tous des
mutinés du bounty cd histoire de
rivalité sexuelle je croyais peut-être
de racisme de la part des européens
envers les tahitiens qui a causé les le
fait qu'il se soit entretués on sait des
choses nature bruno fuligni ou bagnoli
en deuil on a en a comme témoignage
qu'il restait un survivant de l'équipage
du bambou tique quand le bateau anglais
fini par retrouver lille bien des années
plus tard et est donc on n'a que les
paroles de cet homme pour expliquer ce
qui s'est passé puisqu'il raconte
d'ailleurs semble vraisemblable avec la
avec l'arrêt avec une réalité
parfaitement probable
c'est vrai que le beau bout d'un moment
l'isolant fini par exaspérer les
tensions et les rivalités raciale voilà
c'est quand même un impôt fermé ça finit
par exploser et mais ça n'a pas empêché
quand même cette population de de rester
se développer alors passons à amerloques
brando et à son il en est en 1960 sur le
tournage des révoltés du bounty et et
lui ce multi mme carrément contre le
studio qui qui a produit ce film très
gros budget qui va être une catastrophe
financière
il est en mutinerie permanente 1 il
déteste le réalisateur il déteste les
patrons enfin vous le décrivez dans ce
livre c'est le type le plus misanthrope
et plus irascible du monde qui se met à
rêver d'une île déserte
si j'avais été réalisateur la première
chose que j'aurais voulu éviter c'était
travailler avec marlon brando ça valait
vraiment le roi des emmerdeurs à ce
moment là j'avais ce mois là ah la la
tous les témoignages probants il se mêle
de tout il refusait tout discuter
surtout aimé simplement juste ou pour
entraver les choses simples en prof on
sait pas exactement les raisons
profondes mais il voulait pas que ça se
passe bien on a quand même une idée des
raisons profondes c'est le plus grand
acteur du monde à l'époque s'est il est
largement au dessus de tout le monde
il a fait des films formidables début
et puis là il voit bien son métier le
plus grand intérêt les films qu'on lui
propose sont sans intérêt il ne choisit
d'ailleurs que des navets il ne fait
quasiment que des navets pendant
quelques années dont celui ci on voit
bien qu'ils détestent qu'il est en train
de faire quoi et mais il n'a pas
tellement le choix parce qu'on ne
propose rien de mieux jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie il détestera sont utiles il
détestera sa notoriété et détestera lé
milieu dans lequel il est et c'était
marrant parce que quand il était là
quand il tenait son hôtel lui-même à
terroir il voulait bien parler avec les
clients qui connaissait évidemment
immense vedette qu'il était mais mais
dès l'instant où le loup personnes
commençaient à commencer une phrase pour
évoquer sa carrière se fermer communauté
qui n'est absolument pas parler de ça ça
ne l'intéressait pas et voulait vraiment
parler de n'importe quoi sauf de ça et
d'ailleurs toutes les rubis dans
lesquelles il s'est investi
c'était principalement pour s'éloigner
et de son milieu et son talent alors cet
atoll il le visite pendant le tournage
et il est inhabitée mais il appartient à
quelqu'un il va vouloir l'acheter tout
de suite il va mettre quand même pas un
certain temps c'est seulement 1966 qu'il
va être propriétaire de la totalité de
la taule il pas exactement égalité
latence assez marrant tu sais il ya
habité par une personne en fait
exactement 2 1
il est invité par sa propriétaire la
propriétaire ce qu'il avait eue en
héritage de son père l'ancien dentiste
de tahiti dont auquel le roi a fait
cadeau de cet îlot en échange d'un
plombage je ne sais quoi elle a donc été
réussi qu ils étaient contents de ce
service dont qui lui donne une île
déserte et est donné et le dentiste
we accept le plein d'eau s'installe dans
les airs et avec sa fille vient
rejoindre et humeur et sa fille reste
héritière de l'île déserte et décide d'y
vivre mais la particularité de sa qui
sait qu'elle était aveugle et l or elle
vivait dans un paradis à leur santé les
odeurs et l'on entendait les sons mais
elle voyait pas les images et dans une
île qui n'est pas spécialement aménagé
pour les personnes handicapées elle
donc une femme à laquelle qu'il aidait
qui la vie qui l'a dit dès qu'ils aient
il faisait à manger lors des séances on
pouvait attendre d'elle et et pour se
diriger leur étendue des cordes de
cocotiers en cocotiers et donc c'est
comme ça qu'elle passait de son vol
galop à la mère à son jardin donc
c'était quand même déjà bien particulier
donc malgré tout réussi à la quick et où
il y avait beaucoup de ce qui était
atypique ce qui était bizarre qui
ressemblait pas à quelque chose
d'attendu alors marlon brando réussi à
la convaincre
il elle va lui vendre la tonne entre
temps il a enfin obtenu des faveurs de
tarita donc qui d'après ce que vous
racontez était la seule tahitienne sur
le tournage qui lui résistait toutes les
autres couches est volontiers avec
marlon brando celle qu'ils aient trouvé
la plus belle c'était à rita mail rien
elle voulait pas alors c'est l'histoire
on la connaît que par que parce qu'elle
a bien voulu en dire il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup de témoignages sur leur
relation à ce moment là mais c est en
écrivant ces noirs a dit était vrai
qu'elle était la seule à lui résisté
parce qu'évidemment il a couché avec
l'ensemble de comédiens et féminines
brando était un stakhanoviste de la
conquête amoureuse et de et de l'acte
sexuel ils s'étaient tous les jours or
ça par jour et est donc toutes les
filles que c'était une star elles sont
toutes à tomber amoureuse de lui et
tarita prétend que elle a résisté que
c'est peut-être ce qui lui aurait fait
qu' il aurait on aurait pris une place à
part dans ses grâces alors il va il va
donc s'installer sur cette île il y
installe pas taristas d'ailleurs lui qui
préfère le mettre ailleurs
lille c'est pour lui martin rondeau et
la première fois qu'il arrive vous dites
qu'il ya beaucoup de mal à débarquer il
avait vu une île paradisiaque
il ya des cocotiers il ya du sable comme
toutes les îles paradisiaques
mais y accéder pas si facile que ça il
que la première fois qu'ils verront
débarquer sur cette île c'est en sang en
fait il va être couverts de sang oui ça
c'est fort c'est très très loin
il était temps la boue il ya un seul
toit et d'un récif de corail et
il ya des très grosses vagues qui
viennent briser sur ce récif de corail
et c'est après le récif que le labo est
calme et paradisiaque mais faut d'abord
arriver à y rentrer dans un groupe et un
terroir n'y a pas de passes naturel
comme dans le lagon les bateaux ne
peuvent pas rentrer et donc il c'est
très complexe il faut attendre le moment
les bonnes vagues certain moment la mer
se calme
et quand on a un bateau approprié la
fond plat là on peut passer est rentré
dans le lagon et et brando a fait toute
confiance à ses amis tahitien quand la
première fois qu'ils débarquent
mais le problème c'est que ce jour là le
temps était mauvais et vague est un peu
trop groupe oc tahitien hésitait et puis
finalement église bon on y va et brando
la confiance et leur pays connaisse sur
ce que nombre qu'ils n'étaient pas très
doué et le bateau se retourner il brando
tombe sur les récifs et tous ceux qui
connaissent les récifs dans le monde
entier savent ce que c'est c'est
extrêmement violent les blessures qu'on
peut se faire sur le sol et sur les
coraux vivants et est donc brando et
écorché d'un homme talons dida il arrive
pas blessé juste que ça heureusement il
arrive vivent sur leur image
il faut venir un autre bateau avec des
antibiotiques parce qu'il paraît que
quand on sait qu hors jeu très fortement
son corps on a une autre maladie une
infection bactérienne
il est un signe ajouter en plus alors il
qu'on l'appelle parade où les
antibiotiques
il ya un autre bateau et bravo le voit
arriver dire parce que si c'est bon là
là je dois à vie a dit un vieil homme
aux cheveux blancs devant le bateau il
va y arriver et bâle et le type attend
très longtemps très longtemps en choisir
la bonne vague
et quand ils tombent à la rade leur
tourner ce clip et le bateau s'éclate en
mille morceaux et il me répondit que
jamais il croira plus dans la science
nautique des textes alors donc il va
s'installer sur cette île alors au
départ il y vient méditer regarder les
étoiles tous ceux qui sont allés dans le
pacifique c'est à quel point le ciel la
voûte étoilée fascinante puisque
évidemment il ya très peu de lumière en
bas donc on voit les étoiles comme nous
on les voit nulle part ailleurs où à
part dans le désert et
brandao ça dure quelques années comme ça
mais moi c'est ce que je trouve le plus
étonnant voilà un type qui est devenu
misanthrope qui fuient la foule qui qui
construit quand une piste d'atterrissage
parce que c'est quand même à 9000
kilomètres à peu près 1 s'est-il de los
angeles faut qu'il puisse rentrer chez
lui pour fins il est là et au bout de
quelques années il va construire un
hôtel est d'ailleurs taristas qui est
devenue sa femme et la mère de ses
enfants
il va faire travailler à la réception à
mort mais pourquoi brando construite et
d'un hôtel dans son île déserte où il
était venu chercher la paix c'est quand
même un mystère c'est un manque pas
d'argent il en gagne fuite il fasse un
film quand il fait le parrain il a il
avoue quand il tourne cependant je crois
qu'il a cinq minutes dans superman qui
ont coûté à l'époque une fortune aux
producteurs il est à l'abri pourquoi cet
hôtel je dois pas faire la psychologie
de pacotille mais ce point que et là on
peut vraiment être jaloux et d'envié
parce que si un homme au monde qui a
réalisé le fantasme d'une île déserte à
lui réellement déserte et on ne pouvait
pas lui a retiré il était propriétaire
c'est bien lui et pendant des années on
l'apprend cité au maximum ses tunis m
c'est vrai que le climat est
exceptionnel il pouvait dormir dehors il
y avait il y avait à manger
tendez la main pendant un fruit et un
secteur c'était merveilleux donc il en a
profité au maximum mais je crois qu'au
bout d'un moment ils s'emmerdent
sauvegarder et donc la paix il avait
besoin de changer de publier leur but
comme ici c'est elle à lui plaisait
beaucoup il voulait la garder 100 à
inventer une autre
il lui en fallait une autre vraiment
loin loin loin de de son métier et de et
de ce qu'ils savaient faire alors
hôtelier aubergiste ça c'était pas mal
il aurait pu faire plombier zingueur
aussi à ce qu'on la lit il était capable
de prendre n'importe quoi des instances
étaient en rupture avec son métier donc
il sait si vous lui hôteliers et et ses
effets assez drôle parce que vous le
raconter il est assez gros à l'époque
ces postes par un
il est vraiment gros et il est là au
milieu des clients les enfants jouent
avec lui à vos amis d'ailleurs à les
enfants dans cette danse dans l'hôtel
the brando et jouer avec ce gros
monsieur d'authie ne savais pas du tout
que c'était donc quand les avenants
réalité et pas fait le rapprochement
c'est le dessinateur au sailhenc y aller
à plusieurs reprises avec ses parents et
à l'hôtel the brando à tetiaroa mais lui
ne savais pas que c'était une star était
trop petit là et disant regardez pas
encore les films joués brando les
séparent ans savait et tous les clients
qui allaient à l'hôtel the brando savais
que c'était là la star qui n'était pas
toujours la nature mais des fois ils
étaient là comme elle ils recevaient les
clients mais il fallait surtout pas le
dire comme je faisais alors il fallait
pas avoir ce rapport d'admirateurs à vos
dettes sinon tout de suite ils disaient
qu'ils voulaient absolument pas avoir
souvent de rapport mais si on parlait
d'autre chose de plomberie et zinguerie
il pouvait parler avec lui et donc les
gens me regardaient mais discrètement
mais quand ils venaient s'asseoir à la
table des des genres tout le monde avait
les frissons une amende d'avoir marmont
brando à sa table c'est quand même
quelque chose dans tout le monde ne peut
pas raconter aujourd'hui il ya toujours
un hôtel sur l'île s'est il s'appelle
the brando vous voyez d'ailleurs
derrière moi un hôtel extrêmement
luxueux qui coûte très très cher
c'est toujours la famille les héritiers
de marlon brando qui exploite l'hôtel
non c'est pas si l'exploit face à c'est
assez compliqué il ya eu un accord entre
les héritiers de brando et un énorme une
énorme société d'hôtellerie de luxe
internationales pour qu'ils construisent
et qui gère à un hôtel avec 2 millions
des toiles ultra hyper méga écologique
parce que les très très riches qu'ils
aiment beaucoup la grosse écologie et
donc ils ont construit ce palace mais
avec l'accord et en concertation avec
les héritiers bout en bout alors ça que
c'était très mal fini pour les héritiers
brando puisqu'on se souvient de la
sphère cheyenne brando la fille qu'il a
eue avec taristas dont le petit ami a
été tué par le frère de cheyenne le fils
que brando a eu avec taristas prénommé
et christian christian a fait dix ans de
prison et tarita est morte à 25 ans
d'abus de drogue je crois et peut-être
d'alcool c'était chez elles jeudi à
bordeaux sa mère oui mais que j'avais
besoin d'eau etc séchilienne qui est
morte de dauber de drogue ou d'alcool et
enfin elle avait un problème si elle
avait un problème si c'est évident à la
vétéran en clinique plusieurs fois et et
ses tendances suicidaires et les
patients vont table c'est sûr qu'un jour
ou l'autre elles auraient ils auraient
fini par se tuer elle y est arrivée
est ce qu'il y a des histoires d'îles
qui finissent bien
bruno filini parce que on a l'impression
que les il y avait comme une sorte de
destin funeste où ça se sait en droit a
priori paradisiaque où ça se termine en
guerre où ça se termine en colonisation
où ça se termine
parfois avec des hôtels pas toujours de
très bon goût je parle pas de the brando
qui a l'air très joli mais voilà est ce
que est ce que est ce qu'une il peut
rester lille qu'elle était au départ
quand elle nous a fait rêver
je crois qu'on s'y ennuierait beaucoup
si si lille était en permanence l'île
paradisiaque
et quand on regarde quand on scrute les
histoires d'îles on se rend compte qu'il
peut se passer des années des années de
tranquillité de fargniers end mais il ya
toujours le grand cyclone la grande
razia l'équipe et pirates le grand drame
le tremblement de terre qui vient tous
remués tout faire voir recommencer
finalement pas que c'est ça aussi qui
nous rend les îles sympathique c'est que
ça ressemble à des vies humaines au fond
il ya des moments plaisants et des
moments de crise et des moments
dramatiques et c'est pour cela aussi
qu'il ya matière à une collection je
crois je veux
le but de cette collection insulaire
c'est de raconter des histoires vraies
qui ont eu lieu à chaque fois sur une
ide et je voudrais dire qu'ils ne
pouvaient avoir lieu que sur une île et
cci l'une finalement au sens le plus
large
aussi bien des îles naturel
qu'artificielle des îles dans l'océan
que d'eysines fluvial vraiment tout
plaisir quelle que soit leur taille leur
climat quelle que soit la population
restreinte ou immense quelle que soit la
culture
il ya un point commun c'est cela espèce
de huis clos qui peut être parfois
plaisant et qui
bien souvent quand même tourner au drame
oui alors parfois le drame et surmonté
des preuves et surmonter mais les
histoires d'îles les annales un des
populations insulaires
c'est en permanence des des violences
est en permanence des retournements ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on ne s'ennuie
pas finalement sur les îles parce qu'au
moment où on pourrait penser avoir
atteint une forme d' ataraxie et bien
tous au tout tout est tourneboulé par le
cataclysme que personne n'avait vu venir
merci tous les deux je rappelle que
l'île de marlon brando donc le premier
livre de cette collection signées bono
léandri vient de paraître donc aux
éditions du trésor merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous pros au prochain
numéro
[Musique]